yeah there's a really cool cliffhanger
with Hannah
so maybe I'm here maybe I'm not PLL
spoiler alert the season 6 finale just
ended with an unconscious Hannah being
dragged away and only et caught up a
star Ashley Benson for the exclusive
scoop on Hannah's faith let's hope that
Hannah's okay that's all I can say let's
hope that she's alive and doing well
she's like it's question of all this
do you feel like now that the show is on
a whole other level that one of the main
liars could get killed off you know it's
not out of the question
Marlene's kind of hinted at that to just
you know to get the fans like curious I
mean really could be Hanna never know
you may not see me next season you guys
I'm just kidding
but I might be in a lot of danger as
well as all the other liars and the boys
for that matter what's coming up next
and when you guys start season seven we
start in a couple of weeks actually I
have no idea what's gonna be next I'm
really curious to see what happens
you'll see what happens to all of our
characters at the end of the finale and
that's obviously gonna like show you
like what's gonna lead into the next
season I don't know what's going on with
Hanna like I'm actually really nervous
Marlene
Marvy call her right now where are you
yeah just like well actually hope for
Haila
to get back together and then hope that
Hanna is like alive
those are your season 7 wishes yeah
Caleb being my number one